all right it's 9:20 so let's begin so
last time we wrapped up talking about
taxes and consensus and if there are
questions left over from last time I'm
happy to answer them post your questions
in chat or or just ask me whatever it's
a tough topic it's often not covered at
the undergrad level at all I certainly
didn't learn about consensus algorithms
when I was in undergrad so so if you're
still struggling just know that you're
not alone and we're happy to help today
we're gonna move on to something new
so for Monday if you've been reading
announcements or looking at the schedule
you know that I asked you to read the
dynamo paper for Monday the Amazon
dynamo paper so this is one of the most
influential distributed systems papers
of the last 20 years or so it's it it's
highly cited etc etc so we're gonna read
it and talk about it and today I want to
introduce some concepts or start
introducing some concepts that will be
useful for you to keep in mind as you
read it so we've been talking about
about strong consistency between
replicas and we talked about how you
could use primary backup replication or
chain replication as a replication
strategy that ensures strong consistency
and we talked about how in a sense
strong consensus a strong consistency
ultimately relies on consensus because
if you want to be fault-tolerant then
you have to have some coordinator and
that coordinator should really be
several processes that are acting as one
so I really want to emphasize this if
you want to implement a system that's
strongly consistent and you want it to
be tolerant to nodes failing then you're
probably going to need to have some kind
of consensus mechanism sooner or later
so if you were thinking of implementing
homework 3 which asks for causal
consistency by just implementing say
primary backup
location then you're you're going to
have to account for replicas failing and
having to get everyone to to know who
the new primary is if the primary fails
and that requires consensus so that's
not actually the easy way out of doing
the assignment it's actually the hard
way out so I won't stop you if you want
to try to implement consensus in your
spare time but that's not what I
recommend for doing the assignment so
the trouble with strong consistency is
that it's hard to enforce uh so think
about our standard total order anomaly
example that we've seen so many times so
this is a total order anomaly is it a
causal anomaly no how do you know how do
you know that it's not a causal anomaly
well you can't use vector clucks to
figure out which event is supposed to go
first can you know here's here's what
would happen if we tried if this have
been here were say one zero zero zero
so I'm just doing the usual vector clock
thing of saying I'm saying both sends
and receives or events every process
starts out with zeros when you send an
event you send its vector clock when you
receive an event you merge the local
clock with the received vector clock
would look like that so what happens
when we compared these two vector clocks
on these two events is either one of
them bigger somebody asked if this
should be oh yeah I'm sorry yeah that
should be one okay so these two vector
clocks is either one of these bigger so
these two events here are causally
independent in other words causality
tells us nothing about how to order them
so if these had been rights like assign
three to X and assign four to X then we
would end up with different values for X
here on these two replicas well but we
want replicas to be consistent so what
do we do well one option could be to run
a consensus protocol like we've been
talking about to get these replicas to
agree but as we've seen consensus is
expensive it requires sending a lot of
messages and it might not even terminate
so what I would rather do is try to find
some sort of way to make it so that the
order in which these updates arrive at
these replicas doesn't matter and often
that's the right thing to do because
often the order in which updates arrived
really does not matter very much so
what's an example of a situation in
which the order of two updates doesn't
matter
um so well one situation would be if
different keys are being written to buy
these by these two different primaries
or by these different clients right so
if this were writing to Y rather than X
then we would end up with this set let's
see we would have x equals three here
and y equals four here so we would end
up with this set of keys on both
replicas and we don't really care that
the updates land in different orders
because the replicas end up being in the
same state eventually now would this
give you strong consistency recall that
strong consistency means that clients
can't tell that the data is replicated
do you think that if I just said okay
client 1 is only allowed to update key X
client 2 is only allowed to update key
why would this give you strong
consistency according to the definition
that we sketched out before
no it wouldn't exactly because clients
can still do reads during this
intermediate time before both the
updates have arrived on the replicas so
we said strong consistency means clients
can't tell that the data is replicated
so if this client were making queries
about about why and they were making
those queries during this time before
the the update to Y had necessarily
landed here on replica 1 then whether
than the value that they read for Y
would depend on which replicas they
talked to so this wouldn't give you
strong consistency but it's arguably
still better than the situation that we
were in before when both replicas were
updating X and the replicas ended up
different at least here the replicas
eventually agreed um so we can give a
name to this property of replicas
eventually coming to agree
it's called eventual consistency so
informally we can say uh and and we
won't we won't worry about a formal
definition but informally we can say
eventual consistency means that replicas
eventually agree
if clients stop submitting updates so
what kind of property does eventual
consistency look like to you does it
look like a safety property or does it
look like a liveness property
right it's a liveness property so the
fact that it has this word eventually in
it is a hint right so it's a property
that can't be violated in a finite
execution so the first example we had
where one upper replica ended up with x
equals three and the other one ended up
with x equals four in that one even if
you had that you could still satisfy
eventual consistency if you then
implemented some mechanism that made the
replicas agree which would probably
involve them sending more messages right
so eventual consistency is very
different from those other consistency
models that we studied before
so before we talked about we talked
about strong consistency and causal
consistency and FIFO consistency and
these are just a sampling actually of
the many consistency models that you can
have these are all safety properties so
these can be violated in a finite
execution with a vegetable consistency
its aliveness properties so you can't
write down a finite execution where it's
been violated you can only write down a
finite execution where it hasn't been
satisfied yet so I make this distinction
because so eventual consistency has been
a buzzword unless 15 years or so and
sometimes people try to lump it in with
these other consistency models but it
really doesn't belong in this category
at all because it's a different kind of
property so so it's aliveness property
but there actually is a safety property
that we can write down that that
distinguishes between those different
executions that we talked about before
so I will write down that property now
it's called strong convergence so strong
convergence says that replicas that have
delivered the same set of updates have
equivalent state so notice the word set
here so in this picture where we had X
or we had we had client 1 setting with
the value of x 2 3 and we had client 2
setting the value of y 2 4 notice that
those updates came in in a different
order so these replicas didn't deliver
updates in the same order but they
delivered the same set of updates right
at this point at this point you can say
that the set of updates that both have
delivered is the same and so these
replicas are strongly convergent
so the same set of updates in whatever
order regardless of the order they came
in on if they've delivered the same set
of updates if then that they have an
equivalent state we say that they're
strongly convergent so sometimes you'll
hear people talk about a system that has
strong eventual consistency and strong
eventual consistency is a combination of
eventual consistency and strong
convergence
I'll just write down the the definition
of EC again here just so that it's all
in one page
you
so strong eventual consistency is a
combination of those two things so
strong eventual consistency is a
combination of a safety and aliveness
property because eventual consistency we
said is aliveness property and then this
is a safety property so so SEC is safety
plus liveness
so we sort of cheated a little when we
said have client one right to X and have
client - right - why that seems like a
pretty easy way to get strong
convergence right like and it's also
pretty unrealistic like only let one
client write to one particular key and
that doesn't that doesn't seem like a
like a restriction that we really want
to have on our system so can anybody
think of another way that we could
ensure strong convergence that would
still allow multiple clients to write to
the same key are there any ideas how can
we let both clients write to X and still
get strong convergence
you
well okay um yeah you could you could
run a consensus protocol and then say
don't deliver an update until you've had
consensus agree on what order to deliver
the updates so that would be one way to
do it
um okay
but is there any way to do it that's
like maybe a little less heavyweight
than having to run a consensus protocol
what do you think
so here's a hint what have you kept both
rights what if you did something like
this so client one does it's right
client two does it's right so at this
point here on replica 1x is three but
instead of just saying X can only be a
single number we could say X is a set of
numbers and then here when that four
arrives now X is the set three and four
likewise here X is the set containing
just four and here X is the set
containing four and three so since sets
are unordered these are equal at this
point so replicas are one we'll apply
this right and when this other right
comes in it sees that it's concurrent it
looks at its causal history right sees
that it's concurrent and then it saves
both values of x and replica r2 will do
the same thing in the other order um so
the only issue now is that a client
doing a read after this point will get
both values so now it's up to the client
to do any sort of conflict resolution
themselves right and the appropriate way
to resolve the conflict will depend on
the application
um but here we actually do have strong
convergence because the replicas do have
the same set of state after delivering
the same set of updates it required us
to compromise on the on in a way right
because it because now when the client
does a read it's going to see multiple
things but it does preserve strong
convergence so here's an example of of
this situation that's deeply important
to Amazon so let's say that these two
replicas here are both storing my Amazon
shopping cart so let's say client one is
me with my laptop and let's say that so
here's my shopping cart replicated let's
say that with my laptop I add a book to
my shopping cart so here's a picture of
the book so that right arrives here now
here's the set of what my shopping cart
contains meanwhile
here's me with my phone and with my
phone I add a pair of pants to my cart
so then we get here
you
and now replicas have both replicas have
both the book and the pants so now a
client does a read to ask what my cart
is and instead of getting one value they
get two values actually a better way to
understand this this is going to be kind
of messy but if you think of this set
here as being the contents of my
shopping cart so this set is what
replica one thinks the contents of my
cart is this said here is what replica
two thinks the contents of my cart is so
better way to to kind of explain this
here would be to say there's actually
two sets so I have a set of two sets the
set containing the book and the set
containing the pants that's a little bit
messy but but it's actually a more
accurate way to explain the situation so
at this point a client does a read to
ask what the card is and what they get
back is two different carts they get the
cart containing the book and they get
the cart containing the pants so those
are actually two different versions of
the shopping cart what do you think the
client should do to resolve the conflict
yeah just combine them right so the
client should just take the union of
those two sets so the cart at this point
actually becomes both book and pants the
way that I drew it before that that
combination was actually happening here
but it would be more accurate actually
to say that it happens at this point on
the client side the client does the
combination of those two carts this
specific situation is actually discussed
in the Dynamo paper so this definitely
result depends on the individual
application right so in some
applications this won't be the right
mechanism to resolve a conflict but in
this particular application it is the
one that makes sense there's a whole lot
more to say about this and maybe I'll
have time later on to talk about it more
but I want to spend the rest of my time
today on other things on other aspects
of the of the Dynamo paper so this is
this is kind of just a taste of this
problem of application-specific conflict
resolution there's actually a whole lot
more to say about this it's a pretty
huge topic so if you have unanswered
questions I'm not surprised
and but hopefully we'll have a chance to
come back to some of them later but I
want to move on to talk about some of
the other things in the Dynamo paper
because the paper is really just like a
grab bag of different distributed
systems concepts so we have a lot of
other things to discuss as well okay so
setting this aside for now another
concept that will come up in the Dynamo
paper as yareta is that the concepts
concept of network partitions
what does this term mean anyone know
yeah so if you have some sort of network
of communicating computers right you
could imagine
some kind of scenario where some subset
of them can talk to each other and the
other subset can talk to each other but
for some reason there can't be any
communication between the groups so
that's a network partition you can also
have a situation where you have a client
and the client is for some reason able
to connect to machines on both sides of
a partition but for some reason they
can't talk to each other and then rarely
you might have a situation where side
one can send messages to side two but
side two can't send messages to side one
so all of these are network partitions
so network partitions are an unfortunate
fact of life in distributed systems
conveniently we have a way to talk about
them using the fault models that we've
already discussed so we can just use the
omission model right and we can say that
in this case any messages that cross the
partition line are considered lost
messages by the way don't confuse the
concept of a network partition with the
the concept of data partitioning so a
network partition is when parts of a
network can't communicate
and it's generally considered to be a
bad thing right data partitioning on the
other hand refers to when you have more
data than will fit on one machine so you
have to split it over multiple machines
and you have to make a decision about
what to put where so that's that's data
partitioning also known as sharding and
we're gonna talk about that as well
so this is one of those many situations
in distributed systems where we haven't
this unfortunate overlap in terminology
so data partitioning is not
intrinsically bad network partitions are
bad okay so this is a concept that's
going to come up in the Dynamo paper and
um so it's discussed at length in the
paper or it's it's used at length in the
paper so I want you to understand what
it is it's pretty straight forward and
you can reason about it using the
omission model that you already know
about it but in case you hadn't
encountered this term before now now you
know what it is there's another piece of
terminology that I want to introduce and
it's the notion of availability
so dynamo claims to be a quote highly
available unquote system they put that
claim right in the title of the paper so
what it what do they mean by highly
available any ideas what the heck does
that mean
so because they make they describe their
system is highly available that kind of
suggests that availability isn't an
all-or-nothing thing right it's not a
property that's either on or off if
something can be highly available then
arguably it could be a little bit
available or kind of available or mostly
available right so that's the this
notion of availability is a spectrum
rather than an on-and-off thing is is
the right way to talk about availability
so I'll define if it's a perfect
availability isn't really a thing it's
not really possible but but I'll define
it anyway I'll say perfect availability
is every request receives a response
this actually isn't a great definition
because you probably also want the
responses to be fast right and a lot of
real distributed systems work is about
that a lot of the Dynamo paper is about
that but it's an okay starting point
right if every request receives a
response we're in good shape so let's
say that you're trying to do some kind
of replicated system say it's primary
backup replication just for an example
and primary backup replication provides
strong consistency so let's say we have
a primary a couple of replicas we try to
write x equals five let's suppose that
right here there's a network partition
so the primary can't reach the backups
what does P do does it acknowledge the
right to the client
so we're imagining that this new right
comes in and at the moment that P is
supposed to go through the usual primary
backup replication protocol it finds
that it can't reach the backups because
there's a network partition right here
so would it acknowledged the clients
well I guess it depends but normally
under the protocol that we've talked
about so far under primary backup
replication it would not because it
would because the protocol is that it
has to write to all the backups and then
the backups have to acknowledge the
primary right and they can't do that
right now
so it can't respond to the client so
that sucks
right an alternative approach would be
to go ahead and acknowledge the client
and then write to the backups later on
whenever the partition heals but what's
wrong with doing it that way
what if it never heals sure yeah so yeah
you don't know how long this partition
is going to take to heal you generally
think of a network partition as being a
short-lived thing right but but but yeah
the the partition could take an
arbitrarily long time to heal so that's
not great well what else is wrong with
this scenario let's say that let's say
that the partition does heal sooner or
later what else is wrong with this well
yeah what if what if the primary crashes
right the backups don't have all of the
updates so they disagree with the
primary at this point so now if the
primary crashes and a backup had to take
over you've lost a right the client
won't see its most recent rights even
though the client was acknowledged so
the client ought to be able to have some
trust when it gets this okay here the
client ought to be able to have some
trust that the that the storage system
actually got it's right and knows about
it and won't forget so so that's bad too
so both of these situations are bad
right um the situation where where the
primary has to sit here and and wait for
the network partition to heal before it
can talk to the backups is bad because
the partition could take an arbitrary
long time to heal and and and so it
would be pretty slow right and then the
other situation is also bad because
because you could lose data if the
primary crashes so neither approach is
ideal but unfortunately since network
partitions are a fact of life we have to
make a choice between these two very
unappealing options so what do we do and
this is this that the choice that that
primary backup replication makes or any
system that enforces strong consistency
the choice that such a system makes is
to prioritize consistency at the expense
of availability
so under the primary backup protocol
that we've talked about this
acknowledgment wouldn't happen or at
least it wouldn't happen until the
partition healed and if your if you were
defining availability as every request
receives a response let's say within
some fixed amount of time then there
would be no guarantee that that
partition would heal in time for you to
make that in time for your you to honor
that agreement
okay so somebody's suggesting in chat
yeah you could tell the client that we
accepted the right but that there's no
backup yeah so that's an option that a
real system could do right the the the
primary could say okay we've got the
right but no promises man we're just
going to do our best but this right
might get lost you know if I fail okay
or it could be something like temporary
failure try later okay so like that that
would be as sort of that that would kind
of that would satisfy this availability
criterion if you just said try again
later
but that would be a really unsatisfying
way of satisfying this availability
requirement here so it's not really in
the spirit of what we mean by
availability okay so the choice that a
strongly consistent system makes is to
prioritize consistency at the expense of
availability which means that if there's
a network partition which is hopefully
short-lived then it's gonna sit around
and wait for that network partition to
heal before responding to the client and
it's going to make sure that that right
makes it to all the backups before
responding to the client um this is true
not just a primary backup but have been
any strongly consistent replication
system the choice that systems like
dynamo make is to prioritize
availability
at the expense of consistency so you
can't have it both ways
and that's true regardless of the
replication strategy that you're using
um so so more generally um let's just
say that you have let's say that you
have two replicas with a partition
between them and let's say that you had
a client who could talk to both so this
is no longer primary backup um this is a
different service system where clients
are allowed to talk to different
replicas um so let's say that the client
could talk to either replica but the
replicas can't talk to each other so say
the client does a right and it gets an
acknowledgment let's say that the both
both the replicas thought X was for to
begin with so here X has changed to 5:00
on replica one but replica 2 doesn't
know about that then if the client tries
to read X over here now the client asks
r2 what X is so r2 has a choice right r2
could just say X equals 4
if r2 says x equals four that violates
strong consistency because the client
knows that that she just wrote five or
r2 could say well I can't tell you what
X is until I talk to r1
that would violate perfect availability
so this is a fundamental trade-off so
between these two things you can't have
it both ways and we'll talk about that
more in a little while let's pause and
do a quiz question and actually I want
to talk about the last few quiz
responses so I think the I think the
last one we talked about was was quiz
number 13 so so let's talk about 14 okay
so this question was what are the three
properties that consensus algorithms try
to satisfy so we've talked about this a
bunch but so determination they try to
they try to terminate validity they try
to have it be so that the value they
choose is one of the proposed values an
agreement they try to make it so that
everybody actually agrees on one of the
proposed values so validity termination
and agreement and and as we've seen a
consensus algorithm can't actually
satisfy all three so that's what we were
looking for their validity termination
and agreement this next one what are the
three milestones in a run of the paxos
algorithm umm so people wrote all kinds
of things for this one some people wrote
again validity termination and agreement
so that that wasn't the answer we were
looking for here um so so what are the
three milestones so we said the first
milestone is the point where a proposer
gets a majority of acceptors to promise
a particular value that's the first
milestone that has to happen of before
you can move on to the second milestone
the second milestone is when a majority
of acceptors send accepted messages for
particular I'm sorry I probably just
said something wrong what I meant I said
value is that going to go but I met
number so so the first milestone is when
when a proposer gets a majority of
acceptors to promise a particular
proposal number that's what I meant to
say the second milestone is when you get
a majority of acceptors to send the
accepted messages for a particular
proposal number and a particular value
and that's also the point at which
consensus is reached even though not
everybody knows it yet and the third
milestone is the point at which
everybody finds out that consensus is
reached so everybody has heard from a
majority of acceptors about the the
value upon which you've reached
consensus so that's what we were looking
for here the next quiz so those three
properties validity termination and
agreement we are asking which does Paxos
fail to satisfy and how could this
happen
so paksas fails to satisfy termination
and how could this happen
it could happen if you have dueling
proposers so we saw an example of this
last time but you could have a situation
where where two proposers keep on
proposing higher and higher proposal
numbers but they're never never able to
get a majority of acceptors to actually
accept a value that they're proposing so
that that can happen under Paxos and
that's what we were looking for there
okay so those are hopefully now we're
caught up on on quizzes from the last
few classes and here is today's so I'll
send out the link
you
we'll wait a minute longer
yeah it looks like the number of
responses is more or less quiescent so
let's let's let's move on so somebody
just asked um how closely how closely to
read the paper um so I mean this is kind
of a this this is a difficult question
so we're going to we're gonna hit the
highlights of it in class and so
anything that we discuss in class to do
with the paper uh you should consider
fair game for things that I expect you
to know um so I think reading the paper
I think it would be a good idea for you
to read the paper and make a note of
anything that you don't understand and
then bring those questions to class and
it's it you know it's possible that that
some of the paper is ambiguous right and
we don't necessarily have to understand
every detail but but I want you to
understand the big ideas it doesn't hurt
to take notes I liked when I read a
paper I like to read well you know with
my with my pencil in hand and write on
the paper as I'm reading it so that's
how I read I can't really read
effectively unless I'm writing as well
so so I would suggest doing that but
that's that's not necessarily how
everybody learns best so that's that's
kind of up to you I'm not gonna tell you
how to study that's something that
everybody has to figure out how to do
that effectively for themselves so
there's really just one more thing that
I wanted to talk about which is so
coming back to this picture here where
we said okay so so replicas to
has this choice to make right if she if
she returns X is 4 well she knows right
now if that if she tries to ping r1 r1
is unreachable um so so she doesn't know
that she has the most up-to-date value
of X right she could return X right now
and that would violate strong
consistency um whether whether she knows
it or not right whether whether she
realizes it or not the client would
certainly be able to tell that their
previous rate to X wasn't saved so from
the clients perspective strong
consistency would be violated and that's
how we define strong consistency it has
to do with what the client sees and then
this other option if replica chooses I
can't tell you or says something like
well you know I'll tell you I'll tell
you what I have now but you know you
shouldn't trust it
I guess that falls more under the strong
consistency yeah so there's no real good
answer here right and this is a this is
a fundamental limitation of distributed
systems so there's a name for this this
fundamental limitation and it's it's
traditionally known as AZ cap which
stands for consistency availability
partition tolerance so one way to think
of cap which I would argue is not
entirely accurate is you can't have all
three
so consistency availability partition
tolerance pick at most two so that's
kind of the traditional way of talking
about cap but it's actually much more
subtle than that because this is this is
not just any notion of consistency but
this is strong consistency and this is
not just any notion of availability but
it's perfect availability so even though
you indeed can't have strong consistency
and perfect availability and partition
tolerance for the reasons that we just
sketched out here in this little example
it doesn't actually matter that much
because you can provide a system that
has a good enough availability note that
Amazon doesn't claim that dynamo has
perfect availability they claimed that
it has high availability right so what
they do is they choose to turn the knob
more toward availability and compromise
a bit on consistency some other systems
turn the knob toward consistency and
choose to compromise unavailability so
this isn't like an either-or sort of
thing instead it's the thing where you
make particular design choices in your
system that allow you to prioritize one
over the other and there are different
points in that design space it's not
just a binary I'm gonna pick
availability or I'm going to pick
consistency it's it's it's much more of
a spectrum where you can choose
more consistency or more availability um
you typically don't want to sacrifice on
partition tolerance because partitions
just happen
you can't avoid them now some systems
are going to be more vulnerable to
partitions than others and so that might
inform your choices but but you can't
you can't entirely avoid them in a
distributed system so Dinamo makes a
choice that falls more toward the more
availability end of the spectrum and
other systems might make other choices
but don't think of this as like an
either-or sort of thing that's just
about everything that I had to cover for
today and we have about five minutes
left anybody have any questions
questions left over from pack so stuff
or questions left over from the midterm
mmm a question in chat was where's
MongoDB lie on this line um yeah so so I
would put like further toward the
availability and although another thing
to point out here is that these systems
are configurable right and you can so I
don't know that the details of but
there are configuration settings that
you can use to to kind of tweak where
this this this this setting lies so with
dynamo actually so we're going to talk
about we'll talk about this next time uh
but but you could actually configure
dynamo in a way where it falls further
toward this more consistency setting
because it's it's it's what it provides
what's called a quorum consistency which
is configurable uh I I don't know if
does that too I think in general I
would put more on the more
availability side
[Music]
it's just that with dynamo the whole
point of dynamo is that they want to use
it in this more availability
prioritizing mode and that was one of
the things that made this paper so
influential because so there was in at
the time that this that the dynamo paper
was published which was in 2007 the the
tradition in in distributed systems
research was was to was to prioritize
strong consistency and just assume that
strong consistency was always what you
wanted and so there wasn't there wasn't
much research into this spectrum and in
fact the a lot of research was focusing
not only on not only on strong
consistency but on things like Byzantine
fault tolerance and stuff like that and
so the Dynamo comes along and they say
not only do we not care about Byzantine
fault tolerance we don't even care about
strong consistency and so this was
somewhat revolutionary
and it was very influential in many
systems that came later
other questions
yeah yeah so yeah good commented chat so
um so yeah at the time the there was
there was a great deal of focus on on
ensuring strong consistency no matter
what and so so the comment in chat is is
that the Dynamo came at a time when some
companies were doing a lot of over
engineering for fault tolerance and so
if if you choose to take this approach
of of prioritizing availability even
under network partitions then you're
kind of just saying look network
partitions are a fact of life because if
you prioritize consistency right um if
you prioritize consistency then that
means that replica two has to say I
can't tell you to the client or they
can't respond at all right so if strong
consistency is a given if you know that
you have to have strong consistency then
you're gonna do all the work that you
can to try to minimize partitions right
and so well that costs a lot it's it's
um uh and it's and it's not necessarily
the best investment of your resources
right when it might actually be okay for
the client to get a slightly stale value
of x right so that was the choice that
amazon made they said it's most
important that the client receives a
value here it's most important that we
respond to the client's request if the
response to the client's request is a
little bit stale so be it and that ended
up being the right choice the the right
trade-off for their particular
circumstances and that was that was
hugely influential on a lot of other
systems alright let's wrap up for today
we'll talk about dynamo a lot more next
time see you next week have a great week
good